[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بعد فوزه بفتره رئاسيه
جديده في تركيا اردوغان يدعو الى توحيد
الصفوف وتجاوز الخلافات ويعد بتنفيذ ما
سماها قفزه اقتصاديه واعضاء في تحالف
المعارضه يقرون بفوزه وكلجدار اوغلو يدعو
انصاره لمواصله العمل من اجل الديمقراطيه
هجمات كثيفه بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف تقول ان
الهجمات نفذت بصواريخ اسكندر البالستيه
وتطالب بتزويدها بطائرات اف 16 لتعزيز
دفاعاتها الجويه وحاكموا مقاطعه بيل جارد
الروسيه يعلن سقوط ضحايا في قصف اوكرانيا
ساعات من انتهاء هدنه الايام السبعه
المعلنه بموجب اتفاق جده معارك في مناطق
عده في العاصمه السودانيه والطائرات
الحربيه تقصف اهدافا للدعم السريع في
منطقه الخرطوم بحري وزير التنميه
الاجتماعيه السوداني يقول ان مفاوضات
جديده ستجري في جده لتمديد
قضيه السقف الدين في الولايات المتحده تصل
الى تسويه الرئيس الامريكي والرئيس مجلس
النواب يعلنان ان الاتفاق الذي ابرم بين
الحزبين الرئيسيين بشان رفع سقف الدين بات
في طريقه الى الكونجرس والكونغرس يتوجب
عليه اقراره قبل مفادي اموال الحكومه